the greatest hindrance is the fear of
other people's opinions and if we could
just stop living a life of obligation
and start living a life of intention it
would change everything I think it was
like 30 years ago somebody came up to me
and they said how do you do it how do
you not care about all the negative
input you get all the negative feedback
all the hate I go what made you think I
don't care I care so much I am so
profoundly empathetic all those things
really hurt me I just don't let it
Define me and I don't let it set my
course just because you don't let them
redirect you doesn't mean it doesn't
affect you I felt every one of those
stings in my life I just had to decide
do I live for the acceptance of others
or do I live out my own uniqueness and
sense of intention